[Music]
hey
everybody it's us again it's wednesday
yeah this is a good one oh i was so
excited to see this movie and i was so
glad that it came out like as good as i
expected
yeah we also watched uh psycho last
night the original from 1960
and [ __ ] held up yeah i bought him i
bought him like for christmas all four
of them like in a
blu-ray pack yeah yeah it's a psycho one
i hadn't seen it since i was a kid
and uh watched it and it it holds up
it's good oh it definitely does yeah i
remember psycho two being better but
we'll see
i think yeah i think we'll watch two
tonight and maybe three and maybe four
or two for now but uh
this one was a good one um
you know uh kind of reminded
it's a kronenberg flick it's a
conversation yeah brandon cronenberg now
this is only his second movie
as he made one called antiviral which is
uh i've also heard is very good but i
haven't seen that one
yet though this one just came out i
guess it premiered at sundance
back in january and then uh it got like
kind of a wide release
you know not theaters obviously but um
in
october so it hasn't been out that long
yeah he's not copying his dad but you
can see the influence
oh yeah like their styles are very
similar which is not surprising what i
liked about this one is
uh he's showing you how to make a
[ __ ] badass movie without spending 10
billion dollars on the damn thing you
know he just
shows really good locations and real
good interiors and real good exterior
shots
to make the movie look real expensive
really good
um really good uh we call it
uh score kind of kind of got that
creepy industrial kind of sound to it
i don't know if we're not really
industrial it's a good way to put it
it's kind of like
it's like a cronenberg movie yeah like i
said you can
it's weird because you can tell it's a
cronenberg movie
yeah but it but i guess brandon
cronenberg you can tell where the
influence is but
he has his own thing which is like more
of a modern yeah it's more modern
take on it yeah but you can tell that
he's his father son
his shot composition is really good
color palettes real good
you can it's on at certain times he'll
use kind of like a soft
lens on things and then other times it's
real crystal clear depending on what
what emotion he's trying to convey to
you it's a good one
it's a it's called possessor yeah
and i guess you could say
it's about a corporate assassin yeah she
kills people for these corporations so
the corporations can
steal what they own and control
but she does it by possessing the person
and getting them to commit murders and
kill themselves
in public so they have plausible
deniability nobody knows that this
technology exists
but you can possess another person and
run them off a remote control
but it has a lot of bad side effects
which that's what the movie is about
and it's it's like a
cronenberg had a lot of body horror in
it this is like identity horror
that yeah that's a good way of putting
it it's definitely this is like a
psychological horror with some sci-fi
elements it's also kind of like kind of
reminded me of upgrade
i was going to say that too it reminded
me a little bit of upgrade also had a
little bit of a blade runner 2049 vibe
to it
um just in the pacing and the way it was
i mean it was
a little faster pace than that but like
kind of the way it was shot and like
yeah that kind of already sort of should
do it it was kind of like that
so like i said don't go into it
expecting it to be like all
action-packed and [ __ ] it's
it's definitely an art film but i don't
want to say that like to sound
like oh don't watch it because it's like
already farty or anything and it's not
as
far in the future as say like blade
runner all right
i think from what i read on the
wikipedia page it's actually supposed to
be set
in 2008 but in alternate reality 2008.
yeah not that you would know that from
watching it it looks uh the architecture
looks more like something out of james
bond flick
which kind of kind of matches up with
the theme of the movie it's industrial
spies and assassins and
[ __ ] like that and uh
well you know it can't spoil the damn
movie
you know but there's a way that they can
target you as a person and then get one
of their agents to possess your body and
go out
and commit murders and then you can k
then they'll then they'll get
then you'll kill yourself and then the
person that possessed you goes back to
their body
and it's technological it's not
psychic but weird things happen when
you're possessing another
person's body you're you're possessing
their mind
and your identity and their identity can
sometimes get
blended and the corporation has to make
sure who it is they're dealing with all
the time because
when the agent comes back they got to
make sure that it's them and it's not
the
yeah they have to like do a calibration
test like they
they give her a box like andrea
riseborough is in this she's [ __ ]
great in this
yeah um they give her a box of like
things girl from mandy
yeah yeah yeah she does a great job
she's the assassin in it
yeah her name's uh tasia voss that's the
name of her character
but yeah they give her a box that has
all this stuff and she's like yes this
is the pipe and it belongs to my
grandfather this is
the other thing to prove who she was to
prove that she's that she is who she is
that you're not getting any quote
unquote bleed through like from the
other people's psyches and
all this other kind of [ __ ] um but you
know what i mean like
so you have that kind of thing going on
now what's interesting about this and i
didn't know we watched it we rented
this you can rent it on youtube and you
can rent it on amazon prime and it's
only 1.99 to rent it
uh for hd however what i discovered was
that
if you buy it like if you buy i don't
know if you buy
because you can buy it on amazon prime
or i don't know if you buy like the
the actual hard copy like the blu-ray if
you buy that that's the uncut version
and i'm not sure entirely what was cut
out of this version
um i have seen a couple of the scenes
there's it's
a couple scenes of like real extreme
gore um
i think and there's an erect penis in
there um
i know i was watching that i think it
was found flicks and he was like why is
why is everybody so afraid of dongs but
the dogs at the movies
but yeah so i guess there was i can now
that i'm thinking about it i can tell i
i know where that scene probably was you
probably know
yeah and um one of the like i said i
don't want to spoil it but i did see
like some of the stuff that was just
like a second or two because
even without those scenes in there this
is pretty
violent like it goes like it goes a long
time and like i said this is one of
those movies where
you really really have to listen to
everybody's conversations you really
have to like follow the story i i feel
like this is one
that i mean i loved it when i watched it
but then like the more i thought about
it and then the more i read about it
i was kind of like that i liked it even
better because you know what i mean it's
one of those ones where
you definitely would have to see it
twice to like catch everything
because there's a lot of like little
[ __ ] in there like just in facial
expressions and like [ __ ] that they say
and stuff like that
if you liked blade runner you'd like it
if you'd like upgrade you'd like it
if you'd like um
oh [ __ ] video drone you'd like it
it was like video drum kind of it was
kind of yeah it did kind of remind me of
that
like thematically it did because that
was kind of something that was like
taking like something that was taking
your mind over and that kind of stuff
and um yeah and oh jennifer jason lee is
in this as
well um which which is funny because as
soon as they were like sitting she's
kind of like
she's kind of like um andrea
riseborough's character who is you know
the assassin
jennifer jason lee's character his name
is girder she's like kind of her handler
she's like the one that's in charge of
the [ __ ] like all the time
there's a james bond le femme nikita
element
to to it too if you like those movies
you'd like it
um that's probably about it huh
yeah i mean it seems like it's gotten
really really good reviews and
a lot of um horror channels that i watch
um picked this like as one of their
favorite horror movies of the year
like i said it's not super action-packed
or anything like that it's much more of
like a
doesn't really have to be that like it
yeah it's just like a more of like an
unsettling kind of it's almost like a
black mirror episode i want to say like
it has that kind of veneer to it as well
she's got to go into these other
people's bodies and kill them and kill
innocent family members
for her job so and you know what i mean
she's
she's she's a bad person you'd have to
be a bad person to do this
yeah and it does and it doesn't go well
yeah
and you have to kind of like keep
straight who knows who and who's in
whose body
it's a trip i will say that andrea
rysboro and the guy
that plays one of the people that she's
possessing
um i'm not sure what is that russy
sutherland i'm not sure if that's the
actor or not but the
the main guy that she's because she
possesses more than one person but
the main guy that she possesses through
the bulk of the runtime i will say that
both of their acting is so good
that when he was walking around being a
dude and being a dude things but she was
in there
you know what i mean like she was kind
of controlling him i totally bought that
she was in there
and he wasn't acting like her he wasn't
doing anything like that
but just the way that the way that it
was shot the way that
they were moving the way that all this
kind of stuff i totally believed like i
didn't have any problem
knowing like when she was in there and
when she wasn't in there you know what
i'm saying
it's kind of hard to put your face like
it's kind of hard to explain like if you
haven't seen the baby
but i totally i was i totally bought it
i was like yeah she's in his brain and
she's like controlling you couldn't see
her you could anything like that
he was just like looked regular but um
you know
so that was like a really like uh
testament to the acting i think
but yeah this was like really good this
is probably one of the best movies that
i've seen this year
i mean easily uh sean bean is in this as
well
playing a gigantic douche hat oh my god
this guy's such a dick
i put it there with the with her that
other film she was in mandy
yeah about like that even though i think
mandy blew me away
more just because the visuals well yeah
i mean mandy was like a visual
yeah it was like an acid trip and just
like you know all
candy yeah and you got nicholas cage
just crazy and the [ __ ] out and
throughout mandy you know what i mean i
was going yeah that's that was good i
love that you know what's different this
is more like a
more like uh like blade runner or a
video drone
kind of put together yeah it reminded me
i mean the the tone of it reminded me of
blade runner 2049. and visually it
reminded me of
of of um upgrade
yeah it looked like upgrade kinda
yeah and it had like a little bit of a
similar theme
not exactly the same obviously but um
you know kind of similar yeah
corporations messing with [ __ ]
powerful
powerful technology that was like
prototype technology and using it for
their own game
well technology mixed with like organic
which is a very cronenbergian
yeah i mean you know what i mean and i
was just telling him because because i
don't think you've seen
existence which um was a david
cronenberg movie i think it came out in
the 90s 96 i want to say i saw it in the
theater
but um that one had also had jennifer
jason lee in it
some of it's kind of dated now because a
lot of it was kind of like you know
computer hackers and
video games and stuff but he had a thing
where
you had there was like a virtual reality
video game that was almost like being in
the real world
but you basically hooked it into a port
like it right into your spinal column
but it was almost like an umbilical cord
like so because so all the controllers
and [ __ ] like that were like organic
like you would just kind of
massage them and it was almost like a
weird like sexual type of thing it was
like really
lunch yeah it was like really really
like a typewriter yeah it was
it was like that so um so this kind of
gave me a little bit of that vibe too
but
um not but a lot more modern like i said
because some
i saw existence again like recently and
it is like parts of it are a little bit
dated but
you know other than that i actually
really likes that movie it's good man i
mean
he's uh continuing the cronenberg
tradition
without straight up ripping anything off
he's just continuing it you can
you know you know where he got his
influences you know you know
he knows what works and uh you know
we're gonna see some good cronenberg
movies from cronenberg part two
yeah that's something to work part two
yeah and now i wanna see antiviral which
is his first one i've heard that one is
really good as well
i'm sure he'll come up with some crazy
[ __ ] i hope so yeah
now like i said i'm not really sure so
if anybody has actually bought
you know the physical medium of this
movie let me know what they cut out i
saw on like i was watching another
review of it and somebody had gotten
like a screener copy
and i guess that had some of the gore
scenes in it that were cut like i said
it's this is pretty gory but they took
out like a few seconds here and there
like someone's
eyeball getting popped out or something
like that so they took out a little bit
so just like let me know
what was taken out because i i saw two
of the gore scenes that they took out
all right tina's asked us what the
favorite cronenberg movies are
ooh for me to be video drone yeah i mean
it's hard to beat video dremel although
the fly the brood was good too i liked
the brood because that had [ __ ] old
what's his name in there getting ready
to whip your ass it's hard to pick one
yeah i mean we've we've reviewed a bunch
of i think we did we review the brood
we did shivers we did video drum
brood disturbed me as a young child and
i think that was even before
video drone wasn't that before video
drum
the brew yes video
81 i don't know i saw them both on hbo
yeah and i didn't know what i was
looking at i was just what the [ __ ]
you know i think video draw came out
after and that that was [ __ ] weird
too
but the whole idea of these little damn
killer babies running around in their
[ __ ] jammies
killing people and then it leads back to
this dude who's doing some psychic
training or
he wasn't he was a self-help guru
uh on his [ __ ] private compound
made a damn queen ant and that was yeah
that was [ __ ]
and she was popping them she was popping
and then licking them
because even though that was canada
that little complex that they filmed
that at was
like it reminded me so much of
california
going to like the ski resorts to ski
lodges or
going camping uh my mom was riding all
the damn horses and everything all these
little damn
like coda de caza all these little
[ __ ] farms and ranches
they were all had that same architecture
and next to them sometimes would be
little places where they'd have seminars
and [ __ ] this is out in the [ __ ]
outside of l.a you know out in the
mountains it's probably built up areas
now but in the days it was
it was like the country you know yeah
and so
it looked like a place i would have
been to as a kid so it was it was pretty
disturbing remember they had the wood
paneling that was sideways yeah like
that [ __ ] was everywhere all over la
when i was a kid
yeah we had we had a lot of that too
yeah and it's gone now i think all those
those buildings are all old and
abandoned now yeah but
uh yeah so it's just i don't know just
it was the vibe of the time you know i
could i could place myself
in the brood yeah you know and they were
my size
i was a kid yeah at the time so they're
like i could be wearing jammies like
that
yeah you run into some kid in his damn
jammies and he's a [ __ ] mute
he scared me yeah yeah he last did he
direct rabid yeah he did
and he did and we did a review of that
and somebody mentioned dead ringers
which
yeah which on some days is actually my
favorite cronenberg movie look i even
have my dead ringer shirt on today
mantle twins fertility clinic
specializing in mutant women but uh i
made this
i like the way that one looks i'm not
really too interested in that story
it does it's not a very compelling story
it's a psychological horror story more
than
and there's not a lot it's not super
super gory i think we reviewed that one
didn't we like not too long ago
jerome and the brood tripped me out a
lot more than that
yeah you know just something about them
i think yeah
probably the brood is maybe the
creepiest one i think it
i think overall best movie probably the
fly but that might be because that's
kind of his most
accessible one i haven't seen spider in
a long time i remember liking that a lot
videos
was [ __ ] creepy too remember the
homeless shelter that made you watch
tv yeah and then there's the guy who's
nothing but on videotape
talking to you who's wrong and and that
[ __ ] tripped me out when i was a kid
he only [ __ ] spoke to you in the form
of a monologue through videotape
just like television that television was
reality
you know the mind's eye could not
differentiate between reality
and television so television is reality
and television can affect reality that
[ __ ] [ __ ] blew my mind
that's one thing it's like david
cronenberg and david lynch are
and stanley kubrick probably are my
three favorite directors and john
carpenter okay so top four yeah
but the thing about it is some carpenter
but like i said everybody makes a couple
you know [ __ ] the carpenter that
carpenter actually did
yeah a lot of that he just has his name
on it but the thing about
david lynch and david cronenberg is that
those two guys
i am like jealous with about how weird
they are
like i wish i was as weird as that like
because
well because it comes acro it's so
effortless you know what i mean
effortless weirdness effortless
weirdness and like that's kind of like
because sometimes like if you're trying
to be weird like it comes across
as like you're desperately trying to be
weird like look how weird i am
but the two of them just come across as
they're just like [ __ ] weird dudes
that they just have this weird
imagination
and it's like not hard for them that's
just like the way that they think it's
not as weird as you think it is
no it's not that's why it doesn't seem
forced
it has just like i just described it
dude cronenberg just thought
what if the mind cannot differentiate
between what's real on a screen and
what's real in reality
and just go from there what would the
effects be yeah what would happen what
would happen
and that's that's that's what he did
which i mean this
this movie is kind of like that too
where it's you know this one that we're
talking about today possessor
that's kind of like if this technology
existed that you could
essentially insert your consciousness
into another person's brain
and make them do what you wanted them to
do
what would happen like you know what
would the implications of that be like
if something
went wrong the first thing that happened
is that the richest [ __ ] in the
world would have it they tried to make
themselves even richer
which is exactly what they show yeah and
then you'd have to
think about well wait a minute just
because you hijack another person's body
are they gone now are they totally
helpless or can the person being
possessed can they fight back
yeah so that's what's in there there it
is
that's the movie yeah but yeah this is
this is really really a good one so like
i said if
if you want to see it like complete and
uncut i would recommend like
buying it i think you have to buy the
physical copy like the blu-ray the dvd
that's my understanding i'm not sure if
that's true or not the one that you rent
you can rent it for a dollar ninety-nine
like i said on amazon prime or youtube
that one has a few not a lot of time
like a few seconds trimmed out here and
there you just no
no wreck dongs no uh eyeball gouging
no pry doesn't make a big difference i
don't think it makes a big difference
because it's still pretty gory um you
get
a lot of people get um hacked up
this is like really really bloody but uh
yeah this is a really good one like i
said i think that
um that this is probably one of my
favorite ones of the year i would be
surprised if this didn't i mean well the
year's over now but
if i had to make a list of all the
movies that we saw this year i mean i
think this would easily be
top ten i really i really dug it
but uh yeah so i don't know what
everybody's talking about
talking about cronenberg movies yeah
yeah louis says uh
andrea reinsboro starred in a show
called zero zero zero
on amazon which is a really good show
oh i didn't know that she's been in a
couple other horror movies too and i
think she was in a black mirror episode
called crocodile
also um that i think i saw and what the
[ __ ] was the other movie that she was in
she was in mandy i know that
um she was in another one that we saw
not too long ago
and now i can't remember what it is if
you haven't seen mandy see mandy
attila do you see mandy yeah
now everybody [ __ ] wants to bag on
color out of space
that wasn't that bad but i like i liked
color i like mandy a lot better
manny's better but color out of space
because um
actually color out of space we rented it
like right when it first came out but
shutter has it now
like so you can watch it on shutter if
you have that but i think we rented it
when it came out
i guess because in mandy they basically
told nicolas cage they said be at your
nicholas
cageist they were just kind of like just
go nuts man do what you do
and he's like i can do that and he did
and it really made i mean just they just
let him loose
[ __ ] man i should make some movies i
should just have my job should just be
to make
movie ideas yeah i don't
yeah i mean making a movie is a lot of
work
they're like tom make a movie i said all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] on this show over
the years
it could make about 20 movies you
probably could out of just the funny
[ __ ] i said by accident
[Laughter]
yeah i i imagine that's probably the
case it's too bad that i didn't like
write all of it down because i could
think of like all kind of story ideas
and [ __ ] like that
yeah you know what i mean not that i
have time to like write too much
yeah it's just a certain kind of person
to want to make movies
well like i said it's a lot of work it's
a lot of work and
it's a lot of collaboration yeah i mean
the reason that i like writing
is because you can do it by yourself you
can just come up with your own [ __ ] and
you can write it down it's cheap to
produce you don't have to like
hire actors you don't have to have like
all this [ __ ] expensive equipment you
don't have to have all that kind of
product well you know what i mean
you don't have to have all that kind of
you don't have to have a whole crew you
don't have to have all this equipment
you don't have to have all that kind of
stuff
you can just think up a story and you
can write whatever you want to if you
ask me people
movies are dead that's dead i mean
you're gonna get
every year three or four movies that
really stand out that you like
that's not saying much though that's
usually what it normally was
okay you were lucky back in the 80s to
get like
seven good movies in a year that you
liked
you know most of it was trash it was
always trash
and it's gonna continue to be trash it's
gonna get trashier
if you ask me now the the little
independent films
that's really where you're gonna start
that you'll see good [ __ ] there
well like i said you've always seen good
[ __ ] there yeah gonna hit miss though
and these these uh directors have a
half-life you know what i mean
you're lucky to get 10 good movies out
of them most most directors you need to
get four good movies
before it starts being garbage but uh
movies movies of toast yeah louis said
that andrea riseborough was i think she
was in the newest
grudge that's where we are because i saw
that in the theater and uh yeah mango
said that i forgot to mention this but
on netflix
they're having a new series called
uh guide to swear words or something
like that and nicolas cage is going to
be
yeah that looked good i saw that so yeah
i think that comes out next week
actually this friday is uh season three
of uh cobra kai the future
yeah the future is not going to be these
movies the future's going to be series
some of these series will be
documentaries that [ __ ] scientology
documentary is [ __ ] great
all right i'd like to i like to watch
we were watching those that's we were
watching that scientology documentary
with leah remini
and just the way it's edited is [ __ ]
fantastic
it's like a you know what i mean it's
it's a reality based subject and it's
taking you through it i just
i think that's i think it's great well i
like that it's not
real um it's not real over the top and
it's not real
like it's not trying to like overly
dramatize it had a good score
whenever they interviewed people it was
in a real good setting
they shot it the right way they edited
it together it was exciting
you know um that's the future of of
visual
entertainment it's going to be
entertainment mixed with reality
really good documentaries really good
series cobra kai was a really good
series i
i actually got youtube red just to get
cobra kai
now i'm thinking about killing me
youtube red i don't know well because
netflix has covered
right now they bought it so there's no
reason for me to have youtube red
and then um another thing that's just
getting really good and it's gonna be
the king of most of this [ __ ] which is
these video games well yeah i mean like
i said that's been going on for ages
i'm playing metal gear solid five and
it's not perfect man but it that's a
pretty damn close
trainer on how to infiltrate
[ __ ] um uh defenses enemy defenses
there's a lot of military stuff in there
that's accurate
now what isn't accurate is that you're
doing it alone
you never do anything like that alone
you never do anything in a team smaller
than three men
but it's still that's a highly detailed
fun game you know you're listening to
[ __ ]
tapes and interviews and trying to
figure out the main story arc and what's
going on
and making money as a international
mercenary out in the [ __ ]
international waters and
building [ __ ] and [ __ ] you got a
whole team of guys and you're doing
administrative stuff and putting special
gu putting dudes on tasks that they can
do
and it's just like running a business
you know
and no movie could really
uh [ __ ] no no movie is going to be
able to compete with
something like these long long form
video games
um the the the movie
is now basically the epic poem
it's still in the [ __ ] it's now in in
the segment of epic poem
it's got to be told in within about two
hours the story
that's tough to [ __ ] tell it's tough
to tell a story within two hours
you know what i mean yeah so but
this one was pretty good jenny's being
quiet she's like yeah
[ __ ] it well i was being quiet because
you were talking yeah
i got sidetracked yeah tammy said i'm
just saying
i don't we're lucky to get five good
movies a year now i mean i've seen a lot
more than five
good movies well you like you like kind
of movies i don't like though
that's true you have you you have a
little bit i have a lot broader
you have broader tastes yeah okay and
you enjoy storytelling
you write books and stuff i don't really
enjoy storytelling that much
if the story has to be
really compelling for me to be into it
i'm kind of
deadened to that in a certain way i
don't know there's no way
that's a shame yeah i'm too burnt out on
it
tammy said she liked george clooney's
new movie i watched the trailer for that
and that actually looked pretty good so
we might end up watching that one
as well louie says we need to watch the
nexium documentary yes we will get yeah
i want to see that one yeah and then
tila asked if i saw brandon's uh brandon
cronenberg's first movie antiviral i
haven't seen it yet but now i definitely
want to see it because i really really
liked this one
all right so uh you done i'm just gonna
say that you know
[ __ ] it just goes to show you that uh
movies really hinge on a director and a
director if he's got a name he can give
you a good movie
and cronenberg's a solid name across two
generations now i don't know
you know what as you know we were
talking about john carpenter before how
he's kind of hit and miss but it's like
i don't think i've seen a single david
cronenberg movie that i didn't like
no no they're all about they're all yeah
they're all at least worth a watch
yeah yeah even like the really really
old ones like even
so i don't i don't think i've ever seen
one that i didn't like yeah
not not that i can think yeah i've seen
and i've seen almost all of them that's
not the case with carpenter even though
i like carpenters really good work
yeah you do but you know [ __ ] like what
is it ghosts of mars
nah no you know
but i don't think he made that movie
yeah probably not i don't think he was
just saying
that i think he had other people do it
he's like you do it i don't feel like it
i'll just put my [ __ ] name on it i
think uh
i think he i think it was a huge blow to
him mentally
when um the thing got its ass kicked by
e.t
well he said that before that that kind
of um
yeah because it wasn't successful for
and he thought this is the best movie
i've ever made which it was
and then nobody really recognized it
until years later so i can see how you
get a little salty about that
yeah in his the quality of his work
[ __ ] suffered after that
yeah but he had good movies man yeah
uh when when you know in the early part
of his career
but i think i think the thing [ __ ] him
up that was a great movie it's a
masterpiece
yeah hell yeah well yeah i mean it still
is it's like you know everybody's still
[ __ ] hard to
top it even you know it's hard to top
that movie even though the special
effects by today's standards you look at
that you you tell that that's
fake but for me it looks better than
the cg at least it's there well yeah i
mean i say that about a lot of cg
unless the cg is like so seamless that
you can't tell it's like i would much
rather see
the acting the script keith david and
crustle that was a [ __ ] unbeatable
[ __ ] pair they carried that movie
yeah they lived to the very end of the
movie well i mean the whole ensemble was
like really good though yeah everybody
was like
that was a good answer and what and it
was a ballsy move of all male cast
yeah no no women in it yeah and i didn't
notice it as a kid that it was all milk
it just because it fit the seed
it fit yeah you weren't really the
situation yeah they were on some [ __ ]
outpost out in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere
what was the one that we watched the
other oh we were think we were talking
about uh rare exports a christmas tale
that was another one that was uh that
was all male cast yeah but that might
have been why because they were almost
in the thing the thing zach keeps saying
his
has said many times in the comments and
i haven't got to say it yet um
i need that we need to see nocturnal
animals by tom ford
now it wasn't that not based on a book
because i i
feel like somebody keeps recommending
that book to me also but i haven't seen
the movie yet but i will get around to
it i promise
i promise we just have like such a long
list of movies i mean we've we've gotten
like we've got movies that you guys like
some of you guys have sent us that we
haven't even had time to watch yet
so eventually we'll get around to
watching all of them
one of these days all right you uh
you want to wrap it up uh ask me a
question
oh is she saying would it be horror
would it be a horror movie or action the
one that you're making
oh the one i'm making yeah because i
like to think about it
i don't even think about it uh i make
all movies
all different kinds i feel like it'd
probably be an action movie an action
comedy
yeah i don't know don't get me lying
or kung fu or something like that like a
crazy kung fu movie
i hadn't really thought about it
it'd be on the director yeah all right
you you done you wrapped it are we
wrapping it up all right so
it's wednesday today so again we're not
streaming tomorrow or friday
but we'll be back on saturday for our
regular drunken ranting
like we usually do but yeah check out
possessor
brandon cronenberg like i said kids
would chip off the old block didn't he
i guess tina's never seen the thing she
says i keep adding to her list
yeah but we maybe we're talking about
other movies too unlike other people are
talking about other movies
you mean the thing
she's not answering i think she was
talking about the thing oh she hadn't
seen the thing then that's just
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up that's
unacceptable
unacceptable i've seen the thing okay
yes all right yeah i was gonna say i
think she was talking about something
else
all right so we'll see you guys again
live on saturday and thanks for stopping
by
bye